robert spencer
a record was just set it's uh an
astounding number of
self-identified muslims running for
office coast-to-coast in america it's
the all-time record what do you make of
this
well it should be understood that this
is an initiative that has been
undertaken by muslim brotherhood linked
groups for the last several election
cycles and they have the goal of getting
as many muslims into elected office as
possible and so this is a matter of
concern because the muslim brotherhood
is a pro-sharia organization
that considers islamic law to be the
highest law and every other law to be
secondary to it so we have to ask if
these are candidates linked to these
muslim brotherhood organizations then
do they hold to the constitution or do
they hold to islamic law where they
conflict in islamic laws denial of the
freedom of speech denial of equality of
rights to women and so much else and
which way will they come down if there
is a conflict and these questions of
course are never ants never even asked
by the establishment media much less
answered
you